did you see the Golden Globes I didn't
watch it at all
your boy ricky gervais hilarious was fan
did you guys see it
Oh Ricky Gervais spent so hard in the
paint where I was uncomfortable for him
but I was laughing so hard on my couch
oh dude he went and he he basically goes
well my my kind of perspective on being
the host of this he goes it's it's gonna
be the last year I'm ever gonna do it I
know I always say it but this is Lasher
I'm never gonna do it and he said I want
to be like the guy who's sitting on the
couch making fun of everybody he's like
you know that Dinkin invited the party
yes so that that's I wrote these jokes
he goes so hard in the paint dude I
heard like I saw their makeup people and
I was just gonna make up at school and
one of the makeup women said I get it it
was a little disrespectful no so it was
so fantastic you know I end it yeah well
there's a lot of his jokes like that
that he had a Epstein joke where he goes
he said somebody said Epstein didn't
kill himself
and there goes oh I know he's your
friend I know he's everybody's friend in
here and he goes I don't kick him he'd
do it like a super like bombed like the
joke would just hit so hard and he go
yeah and there you go all goes I don't
care [ __ ] off I don't care I really
don't care it's it was so funny maybe
for him you know he ends it he goes so
they doing the last award he goes
alright we're almost done with his
[ __ ] you were almost done just hang
in there were almost done and then he
does he reads the award and he was right
that's it and then everyone's you know
starts having a Z good go go to have
your drinks to your parties take all
your [ __ ] drugs [ __ ] off and then
walks off it was just like such a beast
it's great it was so good man's great
was Felicity Huffman there I was invited
to all those parties Frank Grillo
invited me and I just I can't do weather
little I can't do him but they're all so
it's just such a suck me off party yeah
beer I mean you're yeah
but day uh it was interesting too
because he was talking about how ou
decided kicked it off you'd love the
friend sidekick stopping us now listen
you know you actors and actors get up
here and you get your award and you you
want it you think you're God
you and you the bigger cause stuff like
this he's like but what are you talking
about he is we don't need that
get your ward say thanks get offstage
it's not that big a deal he's like your
buddy fake in here all you were fake he
goes he goes you know how many awards
are up for Apple and the shows he goes
yeah and yet they have kids making the
[ __ ] iPhones using but you don't say
anything about that even less to be
honest if Isis started major streaming
service you'd have your agent calm so
[ __ ] off ie list let's start the show
I love you know I love it I love it I
love it it's so true it was so everybody
in the Hollywood is terrified what
happens in Hollywood is you're terrified
of pissing off the wrong person because
you don't know who's gonna give you a
job
yes and it's such a collaborative
process so you have to toe the line if
the new thing is gender reassignment
surgery if the new thing is that if you
say you're a woman you better say these
are really important you know my
daughter was just telling me that a Girl
Scouts and Boy Scouts in our UNICEF yeah
there's no more girl it's like it's
summer day it's like all right I guess
you outside of joke about Harvey
Weinstein every was oh he goes hold on
he's not my friend
he you guys created it not me he does I
have nothing to do that's your friend he
just kept going out of Miss whole night
[ __ ] it used to highlight what do you
say about Harvey Weinstein he's got his
trial coming up yeah I forget what the
crazy thing is he's not paying any money
great thing is his insurance is taking
care of all the claims she's still got a
hundred million dollars in the bank this
[ __ ] yeah he's going today though
it's all over two accounts right yes I'm
like yeah even though like 30 women
claim it but with the going globe's I
you know what's interesting I used to
work my used to work that stuff I just
worked golden Hall on Academy Awards let
me see this oh yeah um seen any the
thought oh I starred in Netflix is bird
box a movie where people survive by
acting like they don't see a thing sorta
like working for Harvey Weinstein what
you did it you I didn't you did it is
the best job in was ever done the other
thing is these these awards being
broadcast can't last too long because no
one's watching them anymore it's kinda
like Hollywood leader yet stuck in each
other sir no one's do ratings are like
they are Oh see they're op they've never
been lower so it's like no one's
watching because Hollywood is that
they're just holier than now and when
they start talking people are out yeah
it's so good it's all Ricky Gervais set
the whole tempo of the whole show cause
he goes get your ward get the [ __ ] off
say thanks to your agent deal I don't
need a whole spiel on this and let's
just get your word get off nobody gives
a [ __ ] yeah and so people were getting
up man you tell they're like one time
Zac Cal thanks we were doing hangover 2
and Zac his friends was Ricky and I and
Zac is the one guy I can truly say
doesn't like celebrity it's just like he
never has been he's always been the same
guy and always just brutally honest but
hilarious and everything else in and I
said how are you liking how are you
liking your new Fame because I thought
you know I said but you like he goes but
I get to be here in Thailand nobody
knows me so I get to walk around it's
all right he's always been that way it's
not an effect effect ation and he texts
Ricky Gervais he goes when is he
when does Hollywood when does Fame when
is the good part of Fame kick in and
Ricky Gervais texts back on the way down
well yeah well because your boy was on
coming the qartheen copies I'm Phil oh
[ __ ] a Sebastian or not enough
Sebastian was but the you were just I'm
about from hangover Oh Zac Zac was on
there and they're driving down Venice
cos he lives kind of over there yeah and
the drum down Venice and you know the
car stopping people taking pictures and
Ricky owes God man does this ever get
old can you it's just kind of annoying
and try and feel tears in - I'm so bad
what are you talking about let's just
you signed up for exactly you would you
picture move on make people pay your
bills accept what you signed up for
exactly Zac Zac would what when he was
building his house in Venice and the guy
would tell him how much it was and he
goes ah and he look at that he'd look at
all the contractors because
how much maybe it's gonna be another
100,000 awesome great so great now so I
gotta do another shitty movie to afford
this
I need storm of it serious it was like
he's joking that's totally joking he's
lost some weight man yeah I'll tell you
what though those Golden Globes the the
fashion was awful we've gone like five
steps back it was like going we're in
the nineties it was so we're JLo looked
terrible which is hard to do it was very
strange I am very much I I am starting
to realize how important fashion is and
I never thought I'd say this because I
was always the opposite but now maybe
being around you and stuff when I see
somebody who doesn't have doesn't know
how to dress well especially if they're
like a trainer or wherever I go I'm like
lazy
well yeah you need to pay more attention
because it does not a different that's
your about your product this year but it
also is it I'm sorry but when people
have fashion sense it makes the world
prettier interprets it serves a much
bigger purpose than people realize I
think it's well you know what it is an
art its art its art but also it's also
fastest unexpensive
you can get dope stuff at Target or yeah
ah sir
people were talking about Michelle
Williams that's true by the way you can
get you can go to eating your Zara's
isn't so great is it yeah let's tear I
don't know what happened I have no idea
what happened huh but I'll tell you who
was distracting his [ __ ] I'm gonna be
ten percent gay now every time they
showed Brad Pitt it was so distracting
cotton bring him he's he's so goddamn
good-looking he's also been he won that
award last night to soda Joaquin Phoenix
oh yeah I know I I told you how much I
loved you know why Keene made everything
made everyone made the odd made the
Golden Globes eat vegetarian yeah I know
it's plant-based thanks Rocky what is
happening that's him right there
hold on he's here my hair go getting
there listen you know what I do jealousy
both you cuz you can grow your hair like
that like you just don't care
right it's also still he's still at the
top of his game isn't he well I mean
yeah so we'll think of Billy one of the
final last
how old is he 15 some older than that
he's a raging alcoholic for a while
there he smokes smokes a lot yeah vodka
was his choice 50 56 56 Wow
still looks phenomenal when you have all
your hair like that look at her bite in
the lip forget it 9-piece she's gorgeous
too she's also 50 he was distracting
they would show me like could be like
you know old old old mature like Jesus
Christ me so got it oh my got it yeah
you what you won the award he won for
Best Actor I forget what award he won is
that him right there yeah but that's
that's old him with the lung here's the
new one love is here but well I've ever
wanted to do is grow my hair like that
yeah
don't happen just not for you no and I
want to be skinny but day-old H your boy
Quentin Tarantino got up there cuz that
you know one spot time in Hollywood
again which is my favorite movie in a
long time I see it it's so [ __ ] good
but he won it was weird because I liked
him but this was a little off put away
does it because you know usually get up
he and I think people help me write this
and uh you know collaborated on this
writing effort and getting us movie
dunya's but I wrote it myself so there
won't be any that your sleep goddamn
dude he's a genius
he's a genius what's so hard in the
paint yeah you're saying everything
that's worth it is like I wanna seem
like a fun time yeah geez I saw him come
out of his office on a lot when he was
writing I think it was inglorious
basterds roof is a phenomenal movie
which is a phenomenal in my top five
thank you once upon a time Hollywood's
my number one English bastards two or
three look how about Pulp Fiction the
man is a dude he's Ingo it's a whole
different thing jangles my dad watch
that my dad was this is fence a
masterpiece like this right now yeah
yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue oh good
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[ __ ] business